all right now to the latest on the war
in ukraine defense forces are preparing
for a ground assault by russian troops
in the donesk industrial region of
eastern ukraine the local governor there
says that there is no safe place left
and is urging the remaining 350 000
residents to leave
it's a desperate rush to leave
but saying goodbye
is hard
there isn't much left for them here in
the city of slovyansk russian shelling
has demolished homes small businesses
and hopes for aging with dignity and
security
this was my shop here
i have no words lots of money lots of
resources invested
20 years of work
everything is lost
i have no more income
nothing connects us to this city anymore
i'm scared for my wife and my daughter
who is six months pregnant
they need to leave here
especially after what happened yesterday
they hit the city center
russia has already claimed victory in
nearby luhansk now the kremlin is moving
the front line of the war to the front
doorstep of donetsk in the donbass
region
two civilians died after shelling struck
a market in slovyansk earlier this week
the local government is begging
civilians all 350 000 of them to
evacuate
i have no more choice tomorrow
i will join the army
this isn't the first time war has come
to slovyansk it was seized by
russian-backed separatists in 2014 and
recaptured two and a half months later
there's no telling how long these
refugees will have to stay away
or what they'll find when they return
ukraine's military is continuing the
fight
as russia's forces advance
let's go now to our correspondent nick
connolly he is in key following events
for us nick we know that russian forces
have control of half of that critical
dawnbass region that they say that they
want to take what's the latest now on
the offensive to take the remaining half
well there's real fear here in kiev that
russia is on something of a role after
weeks spent taking severe donetsk and
huge losses they took so donetsk's
sister city of less chance in a matter
of days so there's a sense that they
could really be pushing home that
advantage that their new strategy of
focusing their efforts on a pretty small
section the front lines moving away from
trying to do too much what they did in
the early months of this war that failed
so spectacularly that's now really
bringing fruit that you know russia is
outgunning and outmanning basically
ukraine in this conflict and uh that for
now ukraine doesn't have the resources
isn't getting the western support that
it's been asking for and that ukraine's
western partners simply don't really
understand the scale and the intensity
of this war and that all these
deliveries are just going to be too
little too late the only kind of little
shimmer of hope are reports now in the
last few days from moscow that some of
these units might now be taken back into
the russian kind of hinterland to take a
break to re-group and that you know the
kind of tiredness and exhaustion after
months pretty intense fighting is also
uh you know being felt by the russian
troops and that might give kiev a bit of
a chance to bring those western weapons
to the front lines and kind of even
things out a bit
nick we know that residents have been
told to leave the city of sloviansk it
comes just a day after at least two
people were killed
in a russian attack on the market there
are our residents are they heeding the
warning to leave are they able to leave
well as far as we understand it the
figure is all a bit disparate but the
majority of the pre-war population of
ukraine controlled donbass we understand
have already left in the previous weeks
and months most of the people have
stayed not too far away gone 100 200
kilometers from the front lines but as
you mentioned there about 300 000 people
still believed to be there and on the
whole we've seen time and time again
people leaving it too late people saying
i have nowhere to go i don't have
resources no one wants to host me and
basically people wait until they can
hear the shelling in their own homes to
leave by which time it's often too
dangerous and they end up
either losing their own lives or
endangering the people trying to help
them so this time the government is
trying to get in there earlier be more
drastic in its warnings also put more
pressure on people to get out to avoid
them losing their lives and also
endangering the people who then will be
at worst you know in worst case sent in
to help them so that's their hope now
and definitely an expectation here in
kiev that more cities are going to fall
to the russians before ukraine is able
to turn the tables and to start going
back into counterfeit attack
our very own nick connolly with the
ladies tonight from kiev in ukraine nick
as always thank you
ukraine's government estimates that more
than 10 000 of its soldiers have been
killed
in the conflict the international
observers fear that the
actual figure is much higher
some of those wounded are being treated
in hospitals in other european countries
ivan hunchenko got out alive
was badly wounded
defending kiev against russian troops
we discovered them in a forest
we immediately began fighting
we were lucky that day because our unit
left the battle with only two wounded
me and another lad
hunchenko received two bullet wounds and
a shrapnel wound to his legs
he is one of the first ukrainian
soldiers to be treated in germany since
the russian attack began
the medical care the patient received in
ukraine was excellent but he needed
further operations of course to do that
we needed a large team in the
appropriate infrastructure which is
practically non-existent in ukraine at
the moment
six soldiers are being treated at the
louisiana hospital in argen
maxim katavenko was shot at by a russian
tank in the donbas a piece of shrapnel
hit him in the arm
my median nerve is damaged
i can move my hand in this direction but
not in the other
and i can't feel anything in these two
fingers
even if there is peace in germany the
doctors in achen are familiar with war
injuries
we had a lot of experience treating
patients from iraq many years ago
so in principle this is nothing new for
us
but it's not just doctors helping the
wounded
ukrainians who live in argent stopped by
today to wish even a happy birthday
he just turned 37
a brief and welcome moment of
destruction from the war
it's hard to read the news about ukraine
here you are safe and everything is good
planes and helicopters fly and you
aren't afraid
in ukraine it's completely different
everything that flies belongs to your
country's army or that of the enemy
that's scary no it's a natural
so far about 300 people from ukraine
have been flown to germany for treatment
including civilians and soldiers
ivan hunchenko knows one thing for sure
he wants to return and continue fighting
you